superpeople cool high school's new I am
Number Four or so I am number four is
the story of these special people there
are nine all together one through three
have been killed off this is the story
of number four go figure from the title
I don't think this was said in the
trailer if it's not a spoiler because it
was given in like the first 30 seconds
of the movie they're actually aliens
they're special aliens that are here
this other race of aliens led by that
one dude who's a dick in everything's
trying to kill them yeah you know the
guy that Christopher Walken on steroids
guy these days in movies you have three
choices for a villain the Christopher
Walken steroids villain mark Strong or
CGI that's it in this one Christopher
Walken steroids villain so the concept
in the story of I am Number Four is
pretty cool special dude just learning
his powers he's being hunted by a race
of aliens who are trying to kill him and
his protectors Timothy only font he's
cool he's that cool in most everything
he's like a freebie of cool the bad guys
in this movie kind of looked like the
Romulans from the new Star Trek meets
the vampires from thirty days of night
yeah
the concept of this movie though was
really bogged down by the high-school
thing I mean you're this badass alien
with all these special powers and you
have to go to high school can you just
be like John Connor and t2 and never go
to high school worked for him whenever I
see special things taking place in a
high school nowadays I think one thing
yeah especially when he gets a crush on
this girl and he can't get her out of
his mind and Timothy Olli fonts like
were not like the humans we loved once
and it's forever
I was like oh god don't bring Twilight
vibe into this all in all the high
school setting just trivializes this
whole earth is in peril thing however
the climax of this movie was badass it
was some really cool action man cuz he
can move things with his mind this big
beast is coming at him then he catches
the things head with the force and slams
it against the lockers it reminded me of
like God of War when Kratos catches
something with his blades of chaos and
slams it on the ground so that was
really cool
a lot of cool in the end of this
movie I mean laser guns explosions
people flipping things getting thrown
through walls moving things with the
mind actually quite awesome at that
point I kind of got what the movie was
kind of a cool fun movie about aliens
that look like human beings with mutant
powers and you know gotta save the world
and simple not meant to be dude
don't go into it expecting a performance
from Sir Laurence Olivier or some high
school movie mutant powers supernatural
the x-files on steroids there you
go I mean a robotic main character and
nerdy sub character that the main
character takes under his wing a really
hot chick another
the hot chick that you don't see until
the end who has an Australian accent
that is when it's a basic formula and
actually the N does set up for a sequel
so in the first half of the movie I was
like who cares but after the bad ash
throw down and the end of the movie I
was like I'm actually interested to see
what they do with the sequel I want to
see more of these mutant people throw
down it was weird to my surprise I
didn't think I would be but I'm kind of
interested but I will say since the
first half was high school and
the next half was actually pretty cool I
will say this movie could be a fun time
no alcohol required at matinee price see
it at matinee price don't see it at
night don't get charged like double and
you'll be pissed but if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more